Raise Your Hands Up Show me how much you
love life raise both of your hands up
great I'm Lauren
cion and I'm going to give more color on
Vitalia City I'm going to talk a bit
about why it's important and how you can
create an MVP for your new cities and
countries if you want to live listen up
don't look at your phones this is
important you are all infected now with
a terminal disease It's called Aging I
have it too my father has it
too unfortunately he actually got
diagnosed with uh terminal cancer this
month this is life and
death we have to stop around and
dream big we can coordinate to put put
humans on the moon we should coordinate
to cure
aging before this terminal disease kills
you or your loved
ones we should exit this uh regulatory
environment that says that is monopolist
monopolistic paternalistic that tells
you what you can and cannot do with your
own body creating this invisible
graveyard of people dying before they
can get access to life-saving Medicine
just like my father is
denied risky treatment because it's
risky but he's going to die anyway
waiting but there's a antidote drugs
that Target
aging so instead of managing symptoms
keeping people in a poor state of health
for longer we can actually address the
root cause which is aging itself and
prevent these diseases and because aging
is malleable we've shown that we with
dozens of pharmaceutical interventions
that we can slow down or reverse aging
in lab animals so this is possible and
as a founding member of vow a network
Union showing thousands of members can
actually coordinate to deploy millions
of dollars into aging research that's
early stage spin out companies and put
assets on the blockchain and collaborate
um one of them being ready to go into
humans but we're an online community you
cannot give online drugs we need we need
real medicine in a real City we need to
we can accept clinical trial timelines
they they are currently unacceptable
they they take way too long and way too
much money so we can actually make a
warp speed effort not just for the coid
crisis but for heart disease which is a
crisis Alzheimer's is a crisis aging
itself is a
crisis but starting and we've we've
started cities before to fix a crisis
like with Los Alamos for the Manhattan
Project but starting new cities and
countries is hard um so as an MVP I like
this idea of kind of stepping one order
of
magnitude uh further farther than uh
conferences or coing spaces in both uh
number of people and duration
and uh bridging sort of from an online
community to a real permanent City with
these popup cities so that's why I got
involved with vitalic and building zalo
the first popup City in Montenegro it
was life-changing to to have as so many
people hundreds of people likeminded
people um in the same proximity in in
close
proximity and we had healthy food
available inspired by Brian Johnson we
had um we tracked our biomarkers and and
exercise together keeping each other
accountable and so on so next up we go
deeper at Vitalia uh as a the first the
the next popup City in um it's going to
be in the Caribbean island of ratan as
Nicholas
shared and we're going to seed this
permanent new city where we're going to
experiment with a better regulatory
framework to to make faster uh progress
and um have it as a Sandbox right to
accelerate innovation in in this new way
maybe the world can learn and
incorporate what works so join us there
in in in this paradise for escape the
winter if you'd like um if you want to
live longer and um you know the
alignment there is to make death
optional 100% crypto economy is
available and you should go to Vitalia
City and check it out and uh yeah Join
or Die thank
you